oh I just thought we were victorious
we had three targets in our campaign in
the last month or so one was to try and
stop them cutting the tax credits we
think we've done that as I welcomed that
but we've still found in the detail that
families may lose out about 3 billion in
the next few years so we're going to
check that detail but we're claiming
quite a victory on that our second
target was our campaign to prevent the
police cuts which we thought would be a
disaster in the face of the terrorist
threat at the moment and we think we've
reversed that Inc completely but again
we'll look at the detail of that the
third area was social care and what the
Chancellor's done there is allowed local
authorities to increased council tax
with a precept of two percent now I
don't think we've completely won on that
one because that will only actually
tackle half of the deficit that they're
facing and also some local authorities
may not be able to raise that precept so
we're claiming victory on most of the
campaigns we've waged so I'm quite
pleased with that in fact we were
congratulating to a certain extent do
you see that do you think that's gonna
be Hyde's portrayed and seen that it's a
great victory for the Labour opposition
rather than rather a sharp piece of
political maneuvering from the
Chancellor well I like to be honest I'm
not bothered whether it's a sharp piece
of maneuvering or not by him a few weeks
ago it's only three weeks ago you know
these tax credit cuts were going through
we campaigned against them we mobilize
we linked up with conservative backbench
MPs we linked up with the House of Lords
our MPs have been campaigning right the
way throughout the country and their
constituencies and we've been sending
people in to campaign and conservative
constituency's as well and it's worked
and I celebrate that but I'm still a bit
worried and I said in my speech the
devil is always in the detail of this
I'm still a bit worried because we think
we've identified that there may be three
billion still being cut from families so
we'll look at that and we'll have to go
back and start campaigning again do you
think perhaps the danger is that the
abiding image of today will not be what
you're claiming as as a great victory
for your part
in opposition but an image of you waving
around mouths little red book which
seems to be seen by even members of the
Labour Party has a bit of a blunder no
it wasn't a blunder what I was trying to
do
I've been ripping the Conservatives
about what they've been doing in terms
of selling off our assets and today that
put a basically brought forward another
five billion of well our assets the
people's assets for sale and I've been
ribbing them about how much has actually
been going too well to China how much
the Chinese government has been buying
and I this is a contradiction here that
the government has it seems to want to
enable the Chinese well the Chinese
states are nationalized many of our
assets but at the same time it won't do
anything about the allowing the British
government to either bring something
into public ownership or invest so I
wanted to try and get that across as
well and as I've been ribbing them and
so I get across in a bit of a humorous
way so it probably tensions no sales
they took up with a great role model no
not at all but i what i wanted to do is
put george osborne on the spot because
he's been the big advocate of selling
resources to foreign states and that's
actually affecting now our balance of
payments even because a lot of the
resources were selling off other states
are gaining income from it and we're
losing as a result Tom McDonald thank
you for talking to us